AWARDS AND SELLING MORE THAN 20
MILLION RECORDS.
CNN'S CHLOE MELAS HAS MORE NOW
ON JUDD'S LIFE AND LEGACY.
♪ LOVE CAN BUILD
A BRIDGE ♪
>> COUNTRY MUSIC LEGEND NAOMI
JUDD WAS ONE HALF OF THE DUO THE
JUDDS.
♪ YOUR HEART ♪
>> NAOMI JUDD WAS BORN DIANA
ALAN JUDD IN KENTUCKY IN JANUARY
1946, ACCORDING TO THE JUDDS'
OFFICIAL WEBSITE.
THE FAMILY MOVED TO TENNESSEE
WHERE NAOMI JUDD WORKED AS A
NURSE.
BY 1980, SHE BEGAN PURSUING A
MUSICAL CAREER FOR HERSELF AND
WYNONA, THE PAIR MAKING
APPEARANCES ON A LOCAL MORNING
SHOW AS A PROFESSIONAL ACT.
EVENTUALLY THEY PRODUCED A
STRING OF MAJOR HITS, THEIR
FIRST SINGLE HAD A DREAM FOR THE
HEART RELEASED IN 1983, REACHED
NUMBER 17 ON THE BILLBOARD
COUNTRY CHART.
♪ MAMA HE'S CRAZY ♪
>> THEIR NEXT SINGLE "MAMA HE'S
CRAZY" BECAME THE NUMBER ONE
SONG ON COUNTRY RADIO AND WON
THEIR FIRST GRAMMY IN 1984.
OVER THE COURSE OF SEVEN YEARS,
THE JUDDS WON FIVE GRAMMYS AND
HAD 14 NUMBER ONE SINGLES.
THEY SOLD MORE THAN 20 MILLION
RECORDS.
>> WHICH ONE IS COLE PORTER.
>> ASHLEY JUDD BECAME A
CELEBRITY IN HER OWN RIGHT AS AN
ACTRESS.
HEPATITIS C FORCED HER TO RETIRE
FROM PERFORMING IN 1990.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A CURE YET.
IT IS A VIRUS THAT CAUSES
CANCER.
IT IS A VIRUS THAT CAUSES Y
LIVER DISEASE.
>> THE DUO'S FINAL SINGLE, IN
2016, NAOMI JUDD OPENED UP ABOUT
MENTAL ILLNESS, DURING AN
APPEARANCE ON "GOOD MORNING
AMERICA," SAYING SHE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH SEVERE DEPRESSION
AND ANXIETY.
THE SINGER SAID AT THE TIME SHE
WOULD NOT LEAVE THE HOUSE FOR
THREE WEEKS, AND NOT GET OUT OF
MY PAJAMAS AND NOT PRACTICE
NORMAL HYGIENE.
THE SAME YEAR SHE WROTE A BOOK
TITLED "RIVER OF TIME: MY
DESCENT INTO DEPRESSION AND HOW
I EMERGE WITH HOPE," EXPLAINING
HER STRUGGLES.
>> THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS I DO
EVERY DAY TO HELP ME GET OUT OF
THE DEPRESSION.
THE STIGMA IS HORRIBLE.
AND THAT'S WHY I TRY TO SHOUT IT
FROM THE ROOFTOPS AND TELL
EVERYBODY, HEY, IF IT HAPPENED
TO ME, IT CAN HAPPEN TO YOU, THE
GOOD NEWS, THE SPOILER ALERT, IS
THAT I'M RECOVERING, I'M
HEALING.
>> THE JUDDS COMPLETED WHAT WAS
BILLED AS A FAREWELL TOUR IN
2011.
>> THE ICONIC DUO, THE JUDDS.
>> THEY ANNOUNCED EARLIER THIS
YEAR A FINAL TOUR SCHEDULED TO
BEGIN IN SEPTEMBER.
>> THE FINAL TOUR.
>> THEY PERFORMED TOGETHER
POWERBALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
YEARS IN APRIL AT THE CMT MUSIC
AWARDS.
COUNTRY MUSIC HALL OF FAME
DESCRIBED THEIR MUSIC AS
CHARACTERIZED BY DISTINCTIVE
HARMONIES, WITH POWERFUL LEAD
VOCALS AND ACOUSTIC
ACCOMPANIMENTS, WITH ELEMENTS OF
TRADITIONAL FOLK, BLUES, AND
FAMILY HARMONY.
>> I GET OUT THERE ON THE
HIGHWAYS AND I'M JUST A STUDENT
OF HUMAN BEHAVIOR.
LIFE IS ABSOLUTELY FASCINATING.
LIFE IS SO UNPREDICTABLE.
AND WE DON'T KNOW.
SOMEONE SAID IT'S NOT HOW MANY
BREATHS YOU TAKE, IT'S HOW MANY
MOMENTS TAKE YOUR BREATH AWAY.
♪ DADDY ♪
>> THEY WERE SCHEDULED TO BE
INDUCTED INTO THE COUNTRY MUSIC
ALL OF FAME TONIGHT.
♪ TELL